(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to episode two
of the Addy Hour on today's conversation.
We're gonna be jumping
in and focusing on topics
of both stress and resilience.
And again, we're gonna
have two different guests
from different walks of
life who are gonna come in
and talk about their unique perspectives
and some other overlapping
perspectives as well.
So with that, I'm really excited
to introduce our two guests today.
The first is NBA legend, Allan Houston
and Allan is the Vice
President of Player Leadership
and Development for the New York Knicks.
He has a stellar 12 year career
in the NBA is a two-time All-Star
and he's also deeply
involved in the community.
So as a community leader, he's
been able to effect change
through his Allan
Houston Legacy Foundation
and also through fizzle, which
serves underserved youth,
families and communities nationwide.
So wanna go ahead and welcome
Allan Houston to the program.
Thanks so much for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
I'm looking forward to
this fruitful conversation.
- Yes, definitely looking forward to it.
I'm also thrilled to
introduce our second guest
Yale professor, Dr. Rajita Sinha.
Dr. Sinha is the
Foundations Fund professor
of psychiatry and of neuroscience
and of child study at the
Yale School of Medicine.
She's the founding director
of the Yale Stress Center
and she's also an expert and a researcher
who looks at the biological processes
in the brain that underlies stress
and those processes and how they're linked
to some of the unhealthy
behaviors associated with stress
including things like addiction at times.
She's a sought after expert
and contributor on
multiple media platforms.
And she's also conducted workshops
on stress management and self-care.
It's really thrilled to welcome Dr. Sinha
to the program today.
Thanks so much for being here.
- Thank you for having
me, it's my pleasure.
- So I think this is gonna be a very
timely conversation in a lot of ways,
just based on where we are
as a society right now.
But I also imagine that the topics
we'll be discussing
will extends far beyond
what we're thinking about today
and they're just important
life principles as well.
So I'm really, really excited to be able
to walk through some
of these conversations
and to hear about your
experiences as some of your tips
for our audience listeners as well.
But before we get into some of that,
did wanna set the stage a little bit
and just see how both of
you are doing in the midst
of everything that's going on.
And I can say honestly, for
myself there is an element
of tiredness that I feel in this moment.
Some of that I know we're just coming off
for the anniversary,
the one-year anniversary
from when much of the
country went into lockdown.
In some ways, it seems
it's hard to believe
that it's been a year already.
In some ways it's been slow,
in some ways it's been fast
but then also with everything
that we're still fighting
and dealing with around
the racial injustices
really trying to fight
against the systemic
and underlying racism, that's
really embedded in our country
even with some of the news about the trial
that's coming forth for the
former police officer Chauvin
in the case of George Floyd's murder,
all the emotions surrounding that,
all the tensions that we have
with our political system
and some of the challenges
and frankly, ugliness associated with that
which we really emphasize in episode one.
I know for me, as I talked to
family members and friends,
as I interacted with my students,
as I talked to people in the community,
as I talked to people in faith communities
and church communities, it's
really kind of this element
of tiredness and really wanting
to be able to move through
and move forward even though
there's still work we have to do.
So I know there's a lot
there about just curious
how both of you are really
managing everything right now
from what we're dealing with in society
and even in your personal lives.
So, Allan, if you'd be willing to jump in,
I know that that's not a light question
by any means, but important.
- No, but it's a real
question, it's where we are.
As we kind of talked
before we hopped on live.
I think everybody is understanding
we're in a world that
we hadn't seen before.
So we're all trying to navigate it.
For me, we are approaching a
year since kind of locked down.
And I remember literally
March 10th last year
was the day it really kind of hit me
because I was with our
team with the Knicks.
They literally stopped games
and this on March 10th.
And so, I'm just kinda
going back and first of all,
I can't believe it's been a year for one,
and then it's like what was
I doing at the beginning?
I think for me, I have been
to such a busy lifestyle.
Again, it gave me a chance to
spend time at home reflect.
So I kind of had this dual perspective,
one was like, I was
really kind of relieved
that I could just have
a real reason to be home
and not be anywhere else
and engage with my family.
But on the other side, you see the pain
that so many are going through
and the pain that you're kind of sensing
that you don't know how to
kind of deal with and navigate,
because I feel like as a nation
some layers finally
got peeled back, right.
It's almost like we're
kind of getting to the root
and discovery of who we really are
and not who we're portraying
to be as a nation.
And didn't look pretty,
and so we're trying to figure out,
it's almost like living
in a house with a brother
or sister that you still
trying to learn and know
and you find out some ugliness,
but you're still family.
How do we navigate that
and push through it
deal with the ups and downs
which I love this conversation
of stress and resilience
because it's not just
the physical tiredness,
it's the emotional, it's knowing
that I have to endure this,
and I just have to.
So one side it's like, I
know I have to keep pushing.
I have no choice, but on
the other side it's like,
why do we have to keep
going over this again?
And I call myself an eternal optimist.
I have always felt like,
at my perspective is
eternity, or my no God
that has an ultimate
plan and a destination.
So I try to keep that in mind
and kinda work myself back.
But when you get to where you are,
it's a struggle, it's a fight
because not everybody
has the best intentions
and in different experiences.
So it's always a challenge
but at the end of the day,
I just try to remind
myself of why I'm here.
And that's not always to be comfortable
whereas to make a difference.
- Yeah, now that, that higher
purpose in a lot of ways.
And so meeting at the party,
one of the things that really resonated
with me was just the idea of in a sense
like it was a blessing in disguise
to be able to have to
deal with these things
but that doesn't make
it easy by any means.
Like you said, it's things
that were already there
that we have to address head on
but there's almost no escape.
Because now, I mean in this,
there is always a way to escape
but when it's right there
in front of your face,
these are the realities,
then we might have to face.
- I think the thing about escaping
like it seems like this
conversation brought escaping
is not really escaping.
But escaping is not
really dealing with it.
So you're not really escaping.
- (laughs) Very true, yeah.
Yeah, and I think sometimes people think
it's still comes back like you said.
Rajita, what about you in this moment?
- A lot of what Allan was
saying I was resonating with it
I can't believe it's been a year,
it feels like it's gone
by and it's both fast
and slow at the same
time, there were aspects
that I appreciated having moments to think
about things without feeling rushed
cutting out all travel,
which was a blessing.
But, it also really uncovered
a lot of who we are,
challenged us in ways we didn't know
how we would react as both
as a community, as a nation
but just in myself too,
we were challenged in different ways.
And so I think it's been
hard from that perspective.
You have to relearn some
things of how to function
in a very restrictive environment.
Your social network is not
there for you in the same way,
so you sort of have to find a new way
of sort of connecting with people.
And that's a more conscientious way
of putting oneself out
which you can't take things for granted.
And then from a work
perspective, it got very stressed
because there was lots
of sort of restrictions
and there were worries about
how would we get things done
that we have to get things get done.
And then taking care of the
people around me, my family,
personally, it was hard for family members
who one couldn't see,
who were ill and sick.
So there there's that whole
dimension of it as well.
But it's been tough so much more tough
for other people who have lost loved ones.
I had illness in the family
but not not actually lost somebody.
And so I feel a level of gratitude
for what I could sort of manage
and even one was challenged
in different ways.
- Yeah, yeah.
In several ways, it
sounds like you're talking
about just the mixture of
emotions that come to the loss
and then some of the resilience
in the midst of the stress.
And I really like how you brought up
the learning piece as well
because I think that's
been key in a lot of ways.
And some of that has just been
having a willingness to learn
I would say too.
And with learning, always
there are always mistakes.
I mean, I'm sure Allan
you could talk about that
from a sports standpoint,
Rajita from a life standpoint
but really being willing to learn
and have those mistakes happen,
I know for me with my students,
a lot of it has been talking
about basically resetting goals, say okay,
these are the goals I have in mind.
This is a pandemic, I can't
actually meet those goals,
I need to kind of reset and set new goals.
And then I still can't meet
those goals so I reset.
So I mean, it's really a
cyclical iterative process
and not being so hard on ourselves
that we don't give ourselves
that room to learn.
Because as you both mentioned
this is completely new for all of us.
I mean, unless any of us
were alive 100 years ago
we haven't experienced this before.
So there was no template
for how to go through it
but we do have principles
which we can apply as well.
And so I think that's
gonna be a really rich part
of this conversation as well.
And so, I mean, I know you
both already have had passion
about these aspects of
stress and resilience.
And so anything you'd like
to share just in terms
of how you've applied that passion
over the last year in this pandemic
and how other things
that you've had to shift
even in the framework
for how you've approached
some of these things.
- Yeah, no I think the challenge
really got you to think about
one's own sort of sanity first.
Obviously, at your own personal level
and acceptance of what we don't know,
because I remember having this
conversation with colleagues
about whether this is an acute
trauma that we're facing.
And I just said I was on the
other side of it and felt,
and continued to feel that
this wasn't an acute trauma,
like you have a disaster, a hurricane
and of course you deal with
the consequences of the hurricane
but the hurricane leaves,
this is chronic, relentless,
and not knowing at least back
in March and April and May
and through the fall not
knowing when it would end
if it would end in a
way that would be even
at all salvageable as we come out of it.
And then all other
layers, which I know Nii
you referred to in your first episode,
and we may talk about it
but there were other things that got
the onion sort of pulled back
as Allan you were referring to who we are
and different ways and
challenging that also came about.
So I think just for me personally,
there was a lot of acceptance and focusing
and staying with the acceptance
and staying with the multiple
emotions that come up.
I appreciated having time to
exercise more for example,
to have control over your schedule
in a way that you could do those.
So there were some
nuggets of good I suppose
in one's own sort of existence
but it came with a lot of
these other mixtures, so yeah.
- Yeah, I'm curious about
one piece you brought up too
before you pivot back to Allan
but just this idea of it
not being an acute stressor
but something that was much more chronic,
how do our brains respond to that
and what's the impact on
that on us as individuals?
Like how should we be
thinking about the nature
of the stressor itself and
how we approach things?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
And it really gets to the
heart of sort of what is stress
and how do we conceptualize it
and then study it and then deal with it.
Acute stressors are things
that have a beginning
and an end, very discreet.
And they challenge us and
it can be controllable
or uncontrollable, of course,
and uncontrollable really challenge us
in ways that that can probe in a risk
or very quick action to save
us and that kind of thing
but then there's a recovery from it.
And there is a coming
down of our physiologic
as well as our mental processes,
sort of whether it's relief,
whether it's sort of a
sense of accomplishment,
whether it's learning
as you pointed to learning
is a big part of it
adapting to the situation
sort of putting it together to know it
but I'm not gonna do that again,
or I'm not gonna feel that,
and sometimes making
you not growing from it.
Sort of making decisions,
like, I think we're gonna do
this differently the next time.
So you have room to manage that sometimes,
sometimes uncontrollable
stress can be ones
that really challenge you in ways that
put you on the spot to learn in major ways
and you have to be open for that.
The chronic, relentless
is one that unfortunately,
a number of people in our community
already know what that is,
not in the way of the pandemic
but there is a lot of
chronic, relentless stress.
If you were about to
get evicted, for example
or you don't know where the
next paycheck is gonna come
or whether you will have the rent money
and that just like one example of it
but this had those qualities
your own person may not be okay.
You might get affected by this illness
or somebody you love might be,
you might lose someone who's already sick.
There's just a lot of
uncertainty in there.
And like I said, there
wasn't a clear message
about how we were gonna come out of it.
So any ways in which
socially we could get to
sort of gaining control those things
weren't happening in a very concise way.
Some States were better than others,
and we don't have to get
into the social side of it
but just generally thinking
about a stressor is it
was a chronic, relentless,
uncontrollable stress for a long time.
- Yeah that's very, very true.
And Allan you hint into this as well
but how have you been
trying to address that
both in your own life
and in the communities
that you're involved in?
- Mostly just doing this, just talking,
just listening to people,
I think anytime you go through something
I think traumatic, I think
being in a support group
being able to express
and listen to connect
with people who are going
through something similar
that's what I found a lot of strength
and recovery and just connection with.
Obviously, technology
allow that to happen.
So, you kind of get Zoom
fatigue but for the most part,
I felt like as much energy
that got drained from us
I felt like I got energy
from certain conversations.
Sometimes you get on prayer calls
with people and just talk.
And even though like
people are immobilized
and they're sitting in the
same physical situation
or same physical place
you can kind of be moved
in a different way by having
a conversation with someone,
connecting with someone,
just being there to listen to people.
So I think that's one of
the things we've been doing
with kind of our support
groups, mentoring,
leadership development,
just really listening
to a lot of young people,
letting them voice their concerns
voice their aspirations,
just to getting their feedback
on what's going on in their
world and how they interpret
and perceive things that
are going on socially.
I think a lot of people haven't felt
like they had a voice and
they hadn't been validated.
So I think that was
the primary way for me,
kind of in a in a macro
sense to just deal with,
the stress of everything,
connecting with people.
and within myself doing the
same thing, reflecting a lot
just thinking about what's
most important in life
most important relationships.
And just trying to keep it on that plane.
- Yeah, that's so important.
I think there's the element of
community that you brought up
just really giving people the space
to stay engaged in community.
And like you said, re-centering too,
just re-centering in terms of
the strength that we can build
from community and
re-centering spiritually,
I think as well as
strength that we can have
from God in those moments as well.
One piece that I was curious
about from both of you
based on what you've just said
is just if you've seen
specific strengths emerge
that weren't necessarily as evident before
as people have gone through
this chronic stress.
- I think the positive
on the strength of this,
what happened was is related
to what Allan is saying,
which is that it forced us to think
about community in many ways
when people have been busy in their life
or doing the things that they need to do
or struggling and managing things.
And haven't had a chance to
take a step back or reflect.
And this forced us to do
that in top situations
as well as in situations where
you didn't know what to do.
And it allowed us to dig into that sense
of sort of reaching out,
supporting one another using Zoom.
You heard a lot of that using Zoom
or phones or whatever other technology
or just even connecting with
your church groups or whoever,
even you just the neighbors
not that you were seeing them,
but watching them and then connecting
through some media modality
it really allowed you to sort of
get into that connectivity issue
that is so important for humans.
We are social animals
and it was really a good
way to hone into that.
But for a lot of people
and a lot of young people
they really connect
but they miss the other piece, the contact
and you hear that from them.
And so actually a lot of reassurance
and sort of teaching of
patience which is harder,
so I think even that got challenged
while that is a strength
that's perhaps something
that we weren't aware
of how much investment
we need to make in that.
I think we got a chance to
see this, the community not...
you need to fabric not being as strong
as it could have been.
- Yeah, that's really true.
I've had lots of yelling
conversations with neighbors
across the street that
just did in a different way
but it's funny cause you can see
that tension and that desire to,
as people are out doing yard work
and they're getting closer together
then all of a sudden it's like, oh,
I forgot we have to social distance.
It's like yearning to urinate
and it was just starting to bubble up.
So I think you're exactly
right, it's teaching us a lot.
- Yeah, I mean I think
it definitely gave us
a better appreciation for just nature,
just doing the things that
are just natural to us
just walking, talking, exercising,
those things that just help us be whole.
I think that what got
strengthened is as a thing
which you kind of say it's our
ability to think and reflect
it's our ability to think about things.
So to really think about
it a more deeply, right.
And it gave us a little bit
more of a self-awareness
like again, that we didn't like
but we needed to know within
ourselves or just other people.
I know, that's what
they're really thinking.
Now I see what they're really
thinking, I thought it,
but now I'm seeing it, they said it
and we were talking about it
and we're being forced to talk
about uncomfortable things
and things that I didn't
know were not okay to say.
And so those things I think
helped us in a lot of ways.
Now we gotta apply it
and just continue to be
mindful of those things.
But yeah, I agree, I think
those things did help.
Just the idea of thinking,
and I think you made a
great point too as well
'cause I have seven children.
So I see the progression
of an eight year old
all the way up to a 21 year old.
And you realize that the older you are,
the more you're okay with
kind of dialogue and thinking
and that type of engagement
with the younger you are.
I just want some physical
engagement, you know what I mean?
So you really see this natural progression
of how we live and how we develop
and how we really do
need the young people,
the older we are to have
some social engagement
it's extremely important.
And that's why I'm praying
that everything can quicken
so that people can kind
of just get out again
and feel that sense.
- Yeah, that's so important.
Rajita, do you have suggestions for people
in terms of that piece
that Allan just brought out
especially for him, you
mentioned the young people
like still trying to have those spaces
of physical connection,
that's so important.
- Well, the physical connection is tough
because you have to at some
point make the contact,
but I think Zoom goes a long way.
I think people saying using the
different sensory modalities
to connect with other people
I think that's creative
ways in which teachers
and others have reached out to do that.
I've heard for example,
getting kids together
for a joint movement things
whether it's joint dance
workshops or singing together
and yoga together and
some physical activity
in that way has gone on
which has been important and
the kids have enjoyed it.
And again, depending on the age
group, I think that matters.
I do think that the other piece of this
and maybe you were gonna get to it,
is that the need for connection
around the difficulties
that have gone on in
this past year as well,
because I think the children particularly
how you connect on that
is really important
but there has been such a
tremendous amount of loss
in many ways even though we are talking
about we got challenged
and we tried to figure out
how to cope with it and managed
to strengthen those aspects.
There was a sense of loss.
You lost your way of living
and your way of being
and at the most, just at the top level
and then there was lost
in very physical ways
family members losing, I
mean loss had just multiple
levels in the pain related to that.
And I felt like we don't
talk enough about that
because we'd spent so much
time wanting to be as Americans
we like to be upbeat and happy
and oh we're all great and resilient
and not perhaps paying as much attention
to what's coming apart.
- Yeah, that's really important.
So I'm curious, how do you
suggest for both of you
that we deal with that loss
in terms of even just
acknowledging that it's there
but then having the
tools to move through it
and to build resilience?
Because I think in some ways,
sometimes there are misconceptions
about what resilience
really is and what it isn't.
So what would you say to people in terms
of what are appropriate
ways to address those things
and what things should
we be trying to avoid
in terms of how we approach it?
- Yeah, I mean I'll just start
I think what Allan said
is really important.
I think the support and listening
and talking is one of
our very natural tools
but really going to
where the dark side is,
where the darker aspects of
it to not be afraid of that
to reach out about pain and
sadness and about distress
and to stay with it because
we wanna go very quickly
to how do you cope with that?
And what do you do with it?
And there's a natural
way in which that can
as the risk to promote
avoidance in that way.
And so I think the knowing pain
there's a lot of beautiful
historical context of you.
If you know pain, it
gives you the answers,
it shows you what path you need to take.
And so pain and distress
teaches us as well.
And my own personal belief
is, and what I see around
is that we don't pay as
much attention to it.
So there's a risk that people
who are facing the loss
in that very deep way,
tend to put it aside,
not talk about it because
others are not paying
as much attention to it and
have moved on from that.
And so we do a lot of work
around on the trauma of things
and how to accentuate it so that in fact,
not to have people suffer
but to know their pain.
And there's a difference in those aspects.
- That's really important.
- Yeah, that's really good.
I mean, that blessed me, right there Nii,
because I'll be honest with you
I didn't really have a good answer
but when Dr. Rajita
talked about embracing.
That embracing the pain
in a way that you know
that you can get through
it and you can recover.
often when a player gets
injured in sports, for example
I kind of go back to when
I had surgery a few times
and it's painful going
through that process,
the healing, the recovery,
but oftentimes you come
back smarter, wiser
you learn from it.
And the other thing that
I like what you said
cause it's about don't run from pain,
it's almost like, we know a lot of people
who may have an injury or
ailment and you're like,
I'm okay, I'm good, I'm good.
Well, that's one thing
between playing tough
but then another thing is being smart.
And if you ignore that pain,
which I think is given to us too,
it's hey, there's something going on here.
It should be something
you pay attention to
you don't dwell on it, sit in it
think about it, but you
do something about it
you notice it, and then you recover.
And when do, you start to understand
that this pain actually helped me
and I can always recover.
I think that's the one thing
that I always think about is,
when a person gets injured in sports,
you know that especially nowadays
with the medical advancements,
you're gonna recover
and you're gonna be back playing again.
So I think that's the thing that I look at
is from an emotional standpoint is,
I don't wanna be paralyzed by anything.
I want to know that I can overcome things
as hard as they may be
where there's something that has happened
and your relationships, your marriage,
family, things that may have happened
like you just have to think
okay, I'm gonna get through it.
I'm going to bounce back.
And the pain is something
that navigate through.
I often say a lot of people too
like sometimes there's nothing
to do, but to go through it.
- You know, Allan, that's so true.
And yet we spend a lot of time
trying to not go through things
in the way that in fact,
there are social sort of norms about that.
And it's unfortunate because there is,
socially and culturally,
we've had so much pain
that has gone around losing
a son, losing both parents.
I mean, if we just stop for a moment
and think about what that is
how is the person who is
feeling that experiencing
we might start to connect with each other.
We might go back to that
built in coping that we have
which has to do with connection
in a way that we start to
understand each other differently.
- At least you made me
think of something too
that I appreciate this,
that sometimes the pain
we place the pain in the wrong,
no I shouldn't say in the wrong place,
but like when something happens to us
let's us say, a family
member, God forbid gets killed
or a lot of our young
people, there's violence.
And so we know that we're
gonna get through it
but we keep all holding
on to why it happened.
We hold on to the person
that made that decision
to take a life or, and it's almost
like we give them the
license to keep us in pain.
And that's hard, I know it's tough,
but if we dwell on why it happened,
who made it happen, that
becomes unhealthy in itself.
And I think that's where
I think faith comes in
is like look, we have
to learn to not dwell
on why it happened, who made it happen,
but the fact that we can get through it.
- And how do we get through it?
Stay with that.
Now, that's important, I agree with you.
And unfortunately, because we are so wired
to sort of say, well, I can
look weak in facing this.
That is another big
social construct out there
and you take it in your
stride and if you don't,
then you are somehow you're lesser than.
We have a lot of things out there
that get people out of
pain perhaps in the moment,
or they think they get them out of pain
and it just creates more
difficulties later on.
And so that that made things complicated.
- Yeah, so I said, that
ties back even to what Allan
I know you mentioned the
beginning about the escape
and whether that's really escape or not.
So I think you can bring that up as well
just to even bring it home a
little bit more practically,
for a lot of what we're
gonna be going through
I think in the months ahead,
I did want to ask both of you
in this aspect of what you're
talking about how to deal
with the pain and process it,
what things that are coming online
with this Chauvin's trial
and things like that,
all the emotions that we'll
bring to the surface again
with George Floyd's murder.
Are there practical pieces
of advice that you have
for people in terms of how to process that
from a biological perspective,
from a stress perspective,
from a spiritual perspective
and a lot themes we've talked
about I think can be applied,
but it'd be great just to
hear both of you elaborate
on exactly how people should be thinking
about that going forward.
- Yeah, I'll say two things come to mind.
The first is I think in a parallel way
George Floyd's, heinous
murder was May 25th
it was early in this whole COVID piece.
And a lot of what has
gone on and during COVID
unfortunately, the way
people have been dealing
with suffering and pain has been,
we've seen increases in alcohol use,
increases in other kinds of behaviors that
use of pain prescription
pills and other things.
And a lot of that is just
people trying to cope
and figure out what to do.
And so here we are, again in this moment
where some things are gonna come out,
a lot of things are gonna come out.
You're gonna also get reminded flashbacks
of not just the episode and
what happened after that
but everything else that
got uncovered ugliness
or not so ugly things that God said
that really not connecting with each other
as a community evidence of that.
And yet in other ways, as a
community people did rise up
and say, no we're not gonna take that.
There was evidence that
was put in people's faces
that you had to face that I think really
you start by noticing
what is coming up for you.
You start by really a bit becoming aware
of your pain and the
emotions that are coming up
and what else it reminds
you of and sitting with it,
and communicating that to others,
connecting with others, building
more community around it
I think can be very
important at this time.
And really trans then sort
of taking that on and saying
what do we want this to lead to?
Because as part of sort of facing things
we don't give this as much attention
but we as humans really want agency.
And so giving agency in
a way that is adaptive
and solve some things or begins
to help us get through it,
as Allan says, what is going
to help us get through it?
That'll come up if we go ahead
and process it and stay with it.
- That's excellent, that's beatiful.
- I personally don't have a
whole lot of high expectations,
honestly, for the trial.
I think I'm trying to avoid
being too consumed with it.
I wanna be aware of it.
I wanna be aware of what's happens
and how it affects people.
And again, let it continue
to spark dialogue,
healthy dialogue and understanding.
This whole thing has put us
on a really constant
search for real truth.
Cause I feel like in society with people
I don't even think people know
what to even trust anymore.
And so I think you just got
to keep searching for truth
In the Bible talks about
Pontius Pilate asked Jesus,
"what is truth, what is it?"
It's a difference between
information and facts and truth.
So like in this case like this
where the Chauvin or whatever
I think you just got
to look at real motive,
real intent of the heart.
We've done something that
we're doing with talking
with our foundation, we're
meeting with police officers
and seeing how their
sensitivity training goals,
seeing what goes into your
department's development
in these areas just ask
your police department
what are you guys doing
in the area of developing
what kind of training is going
in so you can kind of learn.
I think as community
leaders, we should be aware
of our local law enforcement
practices to train officers.
And so we can just keep
drawing those connections.
So, as Rajita said,
what do we want to look moving forward?
We have to develop more trust
between young people, law
enforcement authority.
And I'll just kind of
end with this thought.
My friend is writing a book in the name
of he's done a lot of
youth development work
and his book is called "Why
Youth Don't Give A Anymore".
That's the name of his book.
And at first I'm like, well,
why do you wanna name that?
But at the end of the day,
young people are looking for models.
They're looking for people to
really model what they expect
and if we don't give them that,
how can we expect them to show us respect
and show authority, respect for authority.
So I think we kind of went
off of that a little bit,
but I think I look at the whole trial,
we're gonna look at so many cracks
in this case, but at the end of the day
like my grandfather used to tell me,
like, you know right from wrong
and make sure you're doing it right.
And make sure you're holding
other people accountable
that in your circle for doing the same.
- That's so good.
And one thing that
seems to jump out for me
from what you both said is
just a theme of understanding
both in terms of understanding ourselves,
when we feel whatever emotions rising up
in response to things and
an understanding others,
and really building those
community bridges as well.
I think it's gonna be really important.
But the one last question
I have for both of you,
just with everything
that we've talked through
that's been so important
I think it's important and great
that we're diving into these tough issues,
because a lot of times these things
kind of get left on the
surface as you both mentioned.
But I also love to hear what
gives you hope in this moment
for really being able to
think forward and think ahead.
- For me, my faith, God.
I just have always relied
on it in my relationship.
It's see me through in the past.
And I think it's like in basketball.
You lose a game, you miss a shot,
something happens, you get hurt.
You go back again and you
get another opportunity
and you believe that you're
gonna make the next shot.
You believe that all the work you put in
and all the preparation you put in
is gonna prepare you for the next time.
And I believe the door is
only once lost in a season
and that's the last one,
every other every other one
is just a learning experience.
The one lost is the one
that you had, right?
So, I kind of look at...
I believe in my ultimate coach has God
and He's gonna continue to
put me in the best situations.
Not every situation is
gonna be comfortable
may not lose, might not win every game
but it's always developing
me, growing me, advancing me.
And I'll just start with that perspective.
And I think what it helps
me do, is we've talked a lot
about pushing through, right?
We had talked a lot
about stress and recovery
The energy that goes up
and then the recovery
that you need to kind
of come back quickly.
So it gives me hope is that
I use my faith to see
the other side of it,
to see the other side of
what's about to happen.
That's how I define faith.
You believe in something
that's going to happen
and hasn't happened yet.
You don't see yet in front of you.
And so I think that's what gives me hope.
I think when I think about relationships
they deep down people, they
want to have a connection,
they wanna have a deeper
connection, understand themselves,
but they haven't learned, they
haven't been in a situation
in environment that's
allowed them to do it.
So a lot of times we get
caught in why is this person
on the main and nasty
and evil and all that?
Well, you gotta think
about where their soil
where their roots are,
where they've come from,
what they've been through.
And then you kind of think, okay
I think that's the way I kind of try
to look at people, look at life.
So I try to see the good side,
see how I can be the part of the solution
and part of the other side of it.
So like during this whole time,
I kept thinking about vision.
Like I kept thinking
about like use this time
to really sharpen your vision.
Since you can't go
anywhere, you can't do much
use it to envision what
you wanna do when you can,
and really train that side.
And that part of and that's kind of
where I still have been thinking about.
So doing that when you start
thinking about what's possible
what you can do, what you wanna do
it helps a little bit more hope come in
instead of looking at what's
going on now, what happened?
You kind of look forward.
So I think that's kind of something
that I've tried to make intentional.
- That's so good in so many
aspects of perspective too
which I know we've talked about
in other situations before
but just that perspective
on the big picture
that God given perspective
that this isn't the end
there's more in a common.
Like you said, just
perspective on learning
and where others are coming from to
what they've gone through
and having that project.
- I just believe too, like I
really believe that's a choice.
A lot of people, you
guys know more than me
like there are some imbalances
and constructs that people have internally
with their genetic makeup
and what's going on.
But I do think that deep down
we have to look at it at
our capacity as a choice.
Like we have a choice
to look at it that way
and believe that, and we
have to use that choice.
- Yeah, I would add, I see
Allan's perspective fully
of what he's saying is so important.
I think the hope for me is
coming from the young people too.
They are not happy,
they are very up set
with what is going on.
Just generally one had to
say, not everybody of course,
but they have forced us to engage
in a way that I had not seen before.
And that it gives me hope
that they have basically
whether it is school shootings
whether it is shooting
violence that we're seeing,
racial violence, whether
it's structural racism
or microaggressions,
or how COVID's response was,
all of those pieces,
how it's affecting them,
they're voicing their pain,
but they're also challenging us
and at a very basic level,
and they're expecting more.
And so I think there's a hope in that
because they've gone approaching life
and approaching what's
happening in the world
in a different way than
when we were younger.
But also I think forcing
us to see their pain,
which makes certainly motivates
me to say, this is not okay.
We've got to do better.
And it sort of appeals hopefully
to our own better angels
to sort of come up
with solutions to break
down barriers if we can,
to sort of think outside the box,
to not get stuck in the choices
as Allan was saying to the sort
of think of alternate things
and alternate choices
and other alternate
perspectives, as you said Nii.
And because it's amazing how that can be.
There are lots of different ways
you just have to open your mind up to it.
And we are faced with a
really lots of challenges,
but the hope is there.
And we have to believe in it
because we have to find a
better place in a better way.
- Yeah, that's so true.
And it ties together
what you're both saying,
both about the choice and perspective
and the choice and action.
I think in a lot of ways
that youth are really
paving the way and showing
us that choice and action.
And I think in some ways
it's up to us to even step up
and step with them in those spaces.
- [Both] Yeah, yeah.
- Join them.
- So--
- And it gets back to that community too.
I feel like we just went full circle.
So yeah, that's a great
way to tie things together.
Well, again, I'm deeply appreciative
to both of you for jumping on the podcast
for jumping into this conversation.
I think there's so many rich pieces
that are gonna be important for us.
I know, even for me,
I'm sure I'll be listening to this again.
There's always even as I'm hosting
there's always nuggets that I pull out
a second time through.
So I know that's definitely
gonna be the case here as well.
So thanks again, both to Allan, Dr. Sinha
for joining on the Addy Hour.
I know this is gonna bless a lot of folks
and be informative and empowering as well.
Definitely appreciate both of you.
- Thank you, Dr. Sinha, it was
a pleasure learning from you,
visiting with you and thank you Nii
thanks for inviting me.
- Of course, of course.
- Thank you, Nii, thanks for having me,
it was a real pleasure to chat
with you and with both of you
and I look forward to hearing
more of the Addy Hour.
- The Addy Hour.
- The Addy Hour (laughs)
(upbeat music)